[Musique]
les hauts fonctionnaires américains se
réunissent au sénat pour examiner la
réponse de donald trump à la crise du
coronavirus le nombre de morts aux
etats-unis étant le plus élevé au monde
l'ancien prête plume de donald trump
networks explique cette gestion de crise
par les mensonges du président en fait
vous savez bob pour être honnête avec
vous bien sûr je le veux j'ai toujours
voulu dédramatiser la situation
je préfère toujours la dédramatiser oui
parce que je ne veux pas créer de
panique
pourquoi avez-vous menti au peuple
américain
pourquoi devons nous croire à ce que
vous allez dire maintenant quelle
mauvaise question tout comme la
terminologie je n'ai pas menti
j'ai dit qu'il fallait que nous restions
calme et que nous paniquons pas rester
calme et continuer à aller de l'avant
c'est ce que j'ai fait cet idiot qui a
écrit le livre a dit en fait trump sait
quelque chose
il voudrait que je sorte en hurlant les
gens meurent non non nous avons fait
exactement ce qu'il fallait
nous devons rester calmes avec tout le
respect que je vous dois c'est une chose
très différentes
mentir au peuple américain l'enduire en
erreur sur une crise qui a coûté la vie
à environ 200 milles personnes personne
ne m'en au peuple américain un jour le
kobe disparaîtra je pense que nous
espérons tous que ce jour viendra et
nous allons avoir un vaccin grâce à ce
président qui se bat contre la
bureaucratie pour avoir un vaccin sûr et
efficace
un jour il disparaîtra cela n'incite pas
à la peur ce président a fait preuve de
son calme depuis cette tribune
il a encouragé la plus grande
mobilisation du secteur privé depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale regardez
certains de ces diagrammes avec plaisir
nous allons les regarder allons-y
si on regarde ce ça commence à monter à
nouveau
tu es bien ici les etats-unis ont le
plus faible niveau dans beaucoup de
catégories
nous sommes les plus bas au monde
la hotte les plus bas au monde plus bas
que l'europe par rapport à quoi
regardez ici voici le nombre de morts il
va disparaître sans vaccin il va
disparaître nous ne le reverrons plus je
l'espère après un certain temps ce sont
pourrait avoir des poussées je
m'attendrais à ça pendant l'automne il
pourrait probablement y avoir des
poussées ou peut-être pas mais vous
prenez les morts par nombre de cas je
parle des morts
rapport à la population c'est là que les
états unis sont très mauvais bien pire
que la corée du sud ou l'allemagne on ne
peut pas faire ça il faut regarder ici
voilà les états unis il faut considérer
des cas chauny charts l'auteur de trump
the art of the hill dit que le succès de
ce livre a ouvert à donald trump la voie
vers la maison blanche
mais pour lui cette expérience l'a mené
à la recherche des parties les plus
antipathiques de lui même trouvant ainsi
le donald trump qui était en lui il se
penche sur ce processus qui lui a permis
de s'en remettre dans un nouveau livre
audio dealing with the devil my mother
child et demi il me rejoint depuis new
york tony merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous comment avez-vous eu l'idée
d'écrire i heart of the deal dont vous
parlez dans votre nouveau livre audio
dealing with des vols faut comparer
trump à gatsby le magnifique de
pacotille quand j'étais journaliste dans
les années 80 je travaillais pour le new
york magazine
j'écrivais de long papier et c'était
impossible de ne pas connaître trump en
fait j'avais écrit un article
extrêmement critique sur lui en 1985 il
était sur la couverture la photo le
faisait passer pour un ben dis donc je
pensais que c'était la dernière fois
qu'ils allaient me parler mais en fait
il a aimé l'article
il a aimé parce que et nous pouvons
mieux comprendre cela maintenant parce
que se voit comme un bandit le faisait
se sentir bien ça ne gênait pas donc
l'attention en elle même était suffisant
pour qu'ils aient envie de continuer
notre conversation
alors qu'on discutait d'une interview
que je devais faire de lui il a
mentionné avoir signé un accord pour
faire un livre
j'ai demandé c'est quoi ce livre il a
répondu c'est mon autobiographie et j'ai
dit mais vous n'avez pas encore
d'autobiographie vous n'avez 37 ans il a
répondu oui oui je sais mais ils me
payent beaucoup d'argent
j'ai suggéré si j'étais à votre place si
j'avais à faire un livre
j'écrirai d art of the deal serait venu
à l'esprit comme ça et cela a
probablement pu
on sait le cours de l'histoire revenons
un peu en arrière
revenons aux médias que vous décrivez
dans ce livre audio parce que certains
vont trouver cela dérange à ceux qui
s'opposent à trump qui ne voteront pas
pour lui en novembre
vous décrivez comment les médias
fonctionner à l'époque je venais
justement de mentionner le new york
times
et si on parcourt les articles on dirait
que tous les journalistes étaient à
l'époque des sténographes croyant donald
trump sur parole sans jamais vérifier la
véracité de ses propos
cela fait partie du succès de trump et
ce genre de génie intuitif qui l'a se
reflète sans doute dans sa capacité à
comprendre que les journalistes se
cherche toujours quelque chose de
nouveau
d'excitant et de controversé et il a
toujours voulu dire ce qui ne se dit pas
il a toujours voulu être
ils ne diraient certes pas mais c'est
vrai le pitre
tant que cela lui apportait de la
tension et les journalistes était
tellement sous le coup de sa
bouffonnerie qu'ils n'étaient pas
critiques face aux conséquences que
pouvait avoir son pouvoir grandissant
c'est ce que je dirai tous les
journalistes qui écrivait sur trump dans
les années 80 peut être même jusque dans
les années 90 devrait prendre en compte
en tout cas j'en tiens compte wada
espérons qu'il y ait quelques honorable
exception mais voilà il a voulu partager
la vence pour the art of the deal pour
le livre et comme j'ai compris une
soirée a été organisée
racontez-nous ce qu'il a dit après la
soirée on parlera de la soirée après si
vous le voulez bien
il a donc voulu de l'argent pour cette
soirée oui il a organisé une soirée à
l'occasion du lancement du livre dans la
trump tower sur cinq étages avec des
centaines de personnes qui l'avaient
invité les célébrités de bas étage celle
qu'il était en mesure d'attirer
avait énormément de monde c'était un
événement très cher et le jour suivant
il m'a appelé pour me rendre compte de
cette expérience et il a dit au fait
toni j'entends bien que tu partages avec
moi les frais la soirée j'imagine que la
soirée avait dû coûter 100 mille deux
cent mille dollars une énorme somme plus
que je n'aurais gagner en l'espace de
toute une année
alors je lui dis de quoi tu parles il me
répond bas on partage l'avançon devrait
donc partager les frais de la soirée
c'était là la quintessence de trump il a
toujours besoin de gagner il a toujours
besoin de dominer et même si je lui ai
donné la chance d'avoir un best-seller
il voulait s'assurer qu'il en sortirait
dans une position dominante à mon égard
apparemment dans tous les cas c'est ça
the art of z il je sais que vous êtes
l'un des principaux chroniqueur mondain
de new york
mais yann frager norman mailer michael
douglas jackie mason que vous citez dans
le livre ne sont pas des célébrités de
bas étage oui mais il y avait 400
personnes ce jour là et vous avez choisi
quatre des dix plus connus oui mais une
question plus importante ici c'est la
facilitation de la montée en puissance
de trump pensez vous que quelqu'un
d'aussi connu dans le monde de la
littérature que norman mailer
pensez vous que tous ces gens aient pris
part à ce processus et le magazine
vanity fair est connu pour être critique
de la présidence de vous isoler et south
à 100% je ne sais pas si on peut parler
de complot mais cette manière de ne pas
percevoir les traits de trump qui se
sont avérées si dangereux étaient
répandues même dans le cas de personnes
comme norman mailer ou même hillary
clinton
trump l'inviter à son troisième mariage
est elle venue oui elle est venue avec
bill avec bill clinton
elle s'est dit ça à l'air amusant sonia
donc oui trump arrive à tirer les gens
vers le bas à son niveau
il allait faire aller à l'encontre de la
meilleure partie de leur instinct c'est
vous voyez vous avez mentionné les
clinton et il y à une célèbre photo de
ensemble hillary clinton disait qu'elle
aurait déclaré la guerre contre la syrie
il y aurait eu des bombardements de
masse sur la syrie sous sa présidence
vous dites que c'est une honte un fini
d'avoir aidé et run mais des millions de
gens dans le monde sont probablement
heureux qu hillary clinton ne se soient
pas installées à la maison blanche les
etats-unis ce serait encore un peu plus
engagés dans le militarisme
vous avez donc peut-être contribuer à la
paix c'est absurde
je ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec ça
je pense que trump
il se dit lui-même président en temps de
guerre
l'équivalent d'un président en temps de
guerre à cause du corona virus sa
manière de réagir face aux coronavirus
sa manière de l'ignorer a eu pour
conséquence deux cent mille morts dans
ce pays
c'est plus que le nombre de victimes
américaines au vietnam
il peut être mauvais pour les etats-unis
mais pour le reste du monde
il n'a pas détruit comme barack obama la
libye le pays d'afrique le plus riche en
terme de pib par habitant
je dis juste que vous devriez vous
attribuer plus de mérite étant donné que
vous dites dans votre livre que c'est
une source de honte et de regret à
laquelle vous n'échapperez jamais est en
fait vous avez rendu un service à
certaines personnes dans le monde et à
écouter chaque décision peut être bonne
pour certains est mauvaise pour d'autres
mais l'effet global de trump est
négative dans des proportions
monstrueuses pour la majorité de la
planète et surtout comme nous le voyons
ici depuis quelques jours dans le
contexte des événements aux états unis
avec la question du changement
climatique
le fait qu'il nie
existence du changement climatique alors
même qu'il a évidemment lieu contribuer
à notre disparition parce que nous
devons lutter pas seulement les états
unis mais le monde entier nous devons
lutter pour faire reculer le changement
climatique si nous voulons avoir la
moindre chance de survivre même pas dit
le 17 septembre
chaque jour de ma présidence sera une
lutte pour un environnement plus propre
et une meilleure qualité de vie pour
chacun de nos excellents citoyens quand
vous étiez avec lui à propos c'est là
l'un des 2600 mensonges qu'il a
prononcés depuis qu'il est devenu
président il contesterait ça mais quand
vous étiez avec lui à écouter ce qu'il
vous disais en écrivant le livre auriez
vous pu imaginer qu'il aurait à faire
face à la mort de tueur 200000 américain
non je ne pouvais pas imaginer qu'il
puisse régner sur ne serait ce que deux
américains en tant que leader donc je
n'imaginais pas un seul instant qu'ils
pourraient un jour emporté un poste
politique donc non je ne pouvais pas et
comment à votre avis at il géré la crise
du coronavirus je dois dire que le taux
de mortalité par personne et chez vous
moins élevés qu'ici au royaume uni je
pense que s'il avait fait les choses
évidentes et logique à faire même si les
avait fait un peu trop tard cela aurait
considérablement réduit le nombre de
personnes mortes du coronavirus est
certainement le nombre de personnes qui
ont été infectées par le coronavirus ici
aux états unis et maintenant chaque
semaine l'élection de novembre étant
proche on a de nouvelles révélations
comme celle d'une agression sexuelle qui
a été évoqué par le guardian
mais croyez-vous les accusations que
trump énergiquement dans l'atlantique
magazine selon lesquelles trump qualifie
les soldats américains morts de losers
ce qui va dans le sens de vos
accusations dans ce nouveau livre
selon lesquelles trump aurait été sous
l'influencé d'un père qui lui a toujours
dit qu'on était soit gagnant soit perdu
toute personne qui a passé un certain
temps avec trump sait que c'est sa
manière de parler et que c'est comme ça
qu'ils voient les choses
il dénigre presque tout le monde
ils pensent que non seulement les
vétérans et les membres des forces
armées
mais les gens de toutes sortes couleur
rouge or sont des perdants et les
crétins par rapport à lui et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils sont selon lui
les loosers et décréta en partie parce
qu'ils prennent au sérieux ce qu'il dit
ce qui au fond de lui il le sait est
absurde c'est toute une série de
mensonges qu'il raconte pour se grandir
même si c'est au détriment des gens qui
le soutiennent
personne n'est plus considéré comme des
losers ou des crétins par donald trump
que ceux qui le soutiennent
en général ce sont des gens avec peu de
pouvoir et d'influencé qui n'ont pas
vraiment réussi dans leur vie d'un point
de vue matériel qui sont en colère ou
qui sait qu'il écarterait s'ils avaient
à passer un peu de temps avec eux c'est
l'un des grands mystères irrésolu de la
présidence de trump pourquoi les gens
qu'ils méprisent sic ouvertement le
respecte tony nous allons faire une
pause l'interview de tonic soir se
reprend dans un instant
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour avec l'auteur de
dealing with the devil tony sharpe
vous dites dans ce nouveau livre audio
que donald trump aurait été un temps je
re roi de bidonvilles et que vous étiez
au courant de cela avant de donner votre
accord pour travailler avec nous comment
vous sentez vous aujourd'hui avec ce lac
j'ai du mal et quand je dis que je
ressens de la honte que je ne peux m'en
débarrasser je pense que c'est aussi
quelque chose dont je ne devrais pas me
débarrasser 30 ans ont passé depuis que
j'ai écrite d art of the deal 30 ans a
essayé d'expliquer cette décision il
s'est avéré qu'il fallait expier encore
plus une fois qu'il a été élu président
mais bon j'avais 33 ans je ne vais pas
me trouver des excuses j'ai fait ça pour
l'argent je pensais que je travaillais
simplement avec un promoteur immobilier
de niveau moyen est un peu beauf on ya
ça n'avait rien d'admirable mais ce
n'était pas bien grave non plus mais
tout de même à un moment donné j'ai fait
une pause et je me suis posé la question
sais tu qui est cet homme c'est us il
est capable de faire de graves chose la
réponse aurait été oui et c'est pour ça
que je dois me racheter
vous savez j'ai vraiment honte du fait
que cette décision tous quel que soit
l'impact et pu l'aider à être élu mais
elle a eu l'effet inverse sur moi elle a
bouleversé ma vie elle m'a complètement
changé vous savez trump a construit sa
vie sur un tissu de mensonges
après avoir étrillé d art of steel j'ai
découvert à propos de moi même et c'est
ironique c'est paradoxal que plus
j'arrivais à m'assumer dans mes
meilleurs aspects comme dans les pires
plus je devenais libre et moi j'avais
besoin de me justifier cette expérience
ce passage vers l'acceptation de moi
même dans toute ma complexité nous
sommes tous complexe a complètement
changé ma vie
elle m'a permis de devenir quelqu'un de
capable de donner aux gens quelque chose
de plus depuis que j'ai fini ce livre
sur trump oui et la moitié de ce livre
est dédié à des méthodes sans doute
utile d'auto guérison
j'y reviendrai beaucoup de théories sont
avancées pour caractériser la présidence
de m
certains journalistes et ses opposants
politiques disent que c'est un espion
russe
ils ont à vous vous évoquez un concept
l'hyperbole véridique
expliquez-nous la notion peut-être que
ça pourrait servir ses opposants qui
sait oui oui
l'hyperbole véridique n'est rien d'autre
qu'une façon raffinée de parler de
mensonge ou de tromperie une telle chose
n'existe pas de par sa définition les
exagérations ou l'hyperbole désigne
quelque chose qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité mais trump m'a dit tant de
mensonges
j'apprenais par son entourage que ce
qu'il me disait n'était pas vrai que je
devais trouver un moyen de faire avec
qui j'ai donc trouvé cette notion
d'hyperboles véridique pour justifier
quelque chose qui ne serait pas vrai il
a adoré l'expression puisqu'elle donnait
de la crédibilité à ceux qui autrement
auraient pu être décriée et qui a été
décrié pendant des années mais c'est
bien de votre faute
j'imagine que cela vous est arrivé de
tomber sur certaines choses qui ont été
discrédités tels que le dossier d'un
espion britannique qui parlait de
chantage concernant la russie et ainsi
de suite
c'est comment avez vous réagi à la
manière dont les opposants de trump ont
fait face à sa présidence étant donné
s'il doit y avoir une explication plus
simple quand acquis et trump plutôt que
toutes ces questions d'ordre
géopolitique et bien ce qui est pratique
c'est que j'étais là depuis le début
pendant toute la campagne électorale de
2015 campagne qui s'est finalement
avérée victorieuse je me suis focalisé
sur son caractère je pense que ce qu'il
a fait c'est qu'il a diminué
l'importance du caractère pendant sa
présidence par son absence de caractère
mais ce dont le monde a vraiment besoin
en ce moment est particulièrement ici
aux etats unis c'est de prendre ses
distances avec l'obsession de
l'individualité du profit personnel
indeed on a besoin de passer deux mois à
nous tromper et la quintessence de
l'individualisme
tout tourne autour de lui en permanence
quelles que soient les dégâts et les
conséquences pour les autres un certain
garrett hardin a écrit un article
fantastique il ya 50 ans intitulé la
tragédie des biens communs l'idée
centrale de ce papier est que si tous
les gens utilisent nos ressources
limitées celle ci peut leur servir
individuellement et à court terme mais
cela détruit les biens communs à long
terme
alors il faut réfléchir à ce problème de
manière plus large
il faut prendre en considération le fait
que nos actions ne sont pas la seule
chose dont il est nécessaire de tenir
compte
bien sûr si nous voulons continuer à
vivre dans un monde durable pendant
encore 10 30 ou 100 ans
mais tony le problème est que ces belles
déclarations que vous venez de faire
correspondre aux belles déclarations de
dison au ronald reagan
barack obama et de beaucoup de
présidents différents ce n'est pas le
cas d'autres
en fait nous entendons ce qu'il pense
nous savons que par le passé vos
présidents ont fait des choses c'est
terrible mais il les avait enveloppé
dans cette élégante rhétorique qui
ressemble à ce que vous venez de dire
stop et transparent le monde peut enfin
voir ce que c'est que la politique
américaine et les américains eux mêmes
peuvent le voir aussi peut-être mais si
les transparences et par le biais du
mensonge c'est donc un menteur
transparent il dit des choses qui ne
sont tout simplement pas vrai
par exemple il dit qu'il n'est pas
important de porter un masque
il rejette sur d'autres la
responsabilité du manque d'efficacité
dans la lutte du gouvernement contre
locaux vides ces choses ne sont pas
vraies et nous savons tous maintenant et
surtout ses ennemis le savent que le
mensonge et sa seconde nature
il ment automatiquement il manque plus
souvent qu'il nous dit la vérité
donc ça c'est transparent mais ils
n'essayent jamais d'être transparent ce
qui concerne la vérité il n'essaie
jamais et ne veut pas dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont mais pourquoi les
gens qui l'entourent limite il fait non
entrés dans la pièce où vous êtes en
train d'écrire le livre parce que vous
dites dans ce nouvel ouvrage que la
moitié du temps il vous était impossible
de le comprendre qu'en est il de son
entourage comment réagit style et est en
quelque sorte le roi avec ses sujets oui
c'est intéressant car je pense que les
gens qui l'entouraient avants ont eu la
même expérience que ceux qui l'entourent
depuis quatre ans contre veut obtenir
quelque chose
il est acharnée sa méthode pour le dire
de manière simple et d'insister insisté
et insisté sur ce qu'il veut jusqu'à ce
que vous leviez les bras en l'air et
disiez ça suffit j'abandonne
il est toujours déterminés et prêts à
tout pour avoir ce qu'il veut plus que
n'importe qui d'autre
il est sans scrupules et n'a aucune
empathique
ce sont les caractéristiques d'un
psychopathe ou d'un sociopathe
cela lui a donné un énorme avantage en
tant que président c'est comme dans un
match de football pendant lequel une
équipe jouerait selon les règles alors
que l'autre ne veut en respecter aucune
donc qui al'avantage c'est lui c'est
l'équipe qui veut tricher voir et bien
vous dites aussi dans le livre qu'en
novembre 87
le wall street journal si je ne me
trompe demander à des gens s'ils
allaient acheter le livre the art of z
il wall street journal le journal
demeure
enfin je suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
murdoch il répondait que personne
n'achèterait ce livre que vous aviez
écrit avec donald trump est bien
évidemment c'est devenu un best-seller
ne craignez-vous pas que les sondages
opposant byden à trump soit un peu du
même genre que ces prédictions de vente
c'est sûrement possible
il est vrai qu'en 2016 est
particulièrement dont quatre ou cinq
états il a largement surpassé les
prévisions des sondages concernant le
nombre de votes
comme je les dis pour moi ça reste un
mystère pourquoi les gens serait-il en
sa faveur à l'heure actuelle mais je ne
crois pas que nous sachions quoi que ce
soit ceux qui affirment pouvoir prédire
le résultat de l'élection
non en réalité aucune idée de ce qui va
se passer je pense que ce sera très
serré entre les deux candidats et
j'ignore à quoi il faut s'attendre mais
ce que je sais c'est que s'il est réélu
ce sera un énorme défi pour l'avenir de
ce pays
et franchement pour toute la planète
puisque ce nouveau livret trait
psychologique qu'il traite notamment de
gens qui de temps en temps se mentent à
eux-mêmes
ne serait ce pas là l'explication du
fait que les gens disent dans les
sondages bien sûr que je ne voterai pas
pour trump parce que ça les gêne de
sentir qu'en réalité ils vont voter pour
lui parce qu'ils sont tout simplement en
colère face à la façon dont les états
unis les traites traitent leurs familles
et leurs proches
d'abord oui il y à un grand nombre de
mécontents dans ce pays il ya la classe
ouvrière composée de blancs qui voient
certainement les choses de cette manière
et il ya sans doute aussi des gens de
couleur qui ne soutiennent pas trump
mais qui sont aussi mécontents
donc oui il y a un très grand nombre de
gens désenchantés et dans beaucoup de
cas ce sentiment est compréhensible
je ne sais pas si ces gens là ne veulent
pas admettre qu'ils sont pour trump
comme en 2016
mais le culte de trump et le tropisme
est largement plus important aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas gênant de
dire que vous êtes pour trump si vous
vivez dans un état républicain et je
crois que la tendance est telle que les
gens seront plus enclins à le dire dans
les sondages cette fois et c'est pour
cette raison que les sondages seront
plus précis mais ils seront certainement
plus fiables al'approche de l'élection
je vais enfin vous poser une question
d'ordre psychologique parce que les gens
sont stressés à cause du coronavirus
quelle que soit la classe à laquelle ils
appartiennent
du moins expliquer nos rapidement ce
qu'est le rythme ultra dhien peut-être
que vous pouvez aider certains de nos
spectateurs
oui mon travail a en grande partie
consistait à aider les gens à construire
une vie meilleure et plus durable à
travers ma société energy project
nous travaillons avec des entreprises
pour mettre en oeuvre l'un des principes
fondamentaux de notre travail quelque
chose que nous avons appris grâce à
notre travail avec des athlètes
professionnels la récupération le
rechargement la reprise d'énergie de
votre propre énergie est aussi important
pour votre efficacité que la façon avec
laquelle vous dépensez cette énergie en
d'autres termes la récupération et le
robot permette d'avoir de meilleures
performances plus longtemps les
entreprises accusés d'exploiter leurs
personnels vont après voté pour trump
dans la reuss belt n'ont écouté les
grandes entreprises doivent prendre
leurs responsabilités
nous avons besoin d'un saut évolutif qui
nous ramènera à ceux dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure il faut combattre et de
manière très sérieuse cet individualisme
qui caractérise tant d'entreprises et
d'individus particulièrement les plus
riches est privilégiée si nous voulons
avancer ensemble
[Musique]